the Joe Rogan experience what did you
hear about about him getting hurt before
the fight I heard that he had a pen
anxiety attack yeah I heard it and I
heard he got knocked out that's what I
heard yeah we're talking about Anthony
Joshua yes I'm saying yeah but for the
people isn't it
we heard that Eddie Hearn is the
promoter of Anthony Joshua and what I
had heard was he got flatlined in
training or dropped and hurt bad and
training yeah and it was like leading up
to the fight like very close to the
fight whether a week or so out with
Jimmy went well I heard that happened
and then he went to Miami to finish the
rest of his camp after that really so
that's what I think
his dad was bitching about like Joshua
I'm not 100% certain but his in the ring
when he was getting into it just like I
told you he won right for the fight he
was you know they were supposed to they
was trying to reschedule the fight yeah
they probably should have their problem
when you get dropped like that because
you see high like the punches you got
hitting weight they don't seem like
punches that would you also looked a
little out of it out of it what's all
this it's easy to say that they laughter
yeah but Andy Ruiz is a bad [ __ ]
dude that guy throws combinations man
Andy Ruiz is a bad [ __ ] you know
people just get confused and they look
at that belly if you took all that fat
away and you saw what was underneath it
and he fought the same way but he
weighed 220 you go wow he's got a
receiver Instagram videos I'm training
how fast I'm like fast as [ __ ] confusing
listen when I when they told me to film
him I think he might have had 20,000
Cisco
I'm twenty thousand followers and then
in one night yeah like a million I'm
like like and he seemed like a humble
guy he keep like trying to promote
Snickers Snickers like every day
Snickers Nick he want that sponsorship
Snickers need to give my sponsors
he's like Snickers he's a big boy he's a
big boy lucky what do you think happens
they're gonna do a rematch yeah and uh
yesterday yesterday Ruiz jr. said imma
beat him worse because I'm gonna be in
better shape
he can't box and I was like whoa he was
Olympic gold medalist he can fire
he can find him bugs hey I just well it
sucks cuz I was gonna cover big baby
Miller
I think he's [ __ ] if he fights Deonte
I think Joshua just can't he can't hold
up onto that firepower
Deonte hits people it's like he's got
some [ __ ] mortal kombat superpower in
his glove it's crazy yeah he got that
old slave genetics well he's got that
Tommy Hearns frame - is I got giant
Tommy Hearns where's all that leverage
all that Shh all that torque he hit so
goddamn hard when you look at a guy that
has what does he have like 40 wins 39
chaos at some point that 41 wins 40
chaos or something crazy well you know
the only money didn't ko is as we talked
about before was Tyson Fury and but if
you looked at the count if you had a
real clock and you hit stop or you hit
start when he went down instead of
relying on the referee to go one two
maybe Tyson would have gotten up because
he would have known that it was eight
when it was eight because the referee
was saying eight it was already 10 you
know it was like one two by the time he
got to eight and nine and Tyson stood up
ten had long been past
so technically yeah but that was also
the case with Buster Douglas and Mike
Tyson you know yeah I talked to Mike
Tyson knocked down Buster Douglas Buster
Douglas did not get up by the count of
10 no on a real count of 10 an actual
10-second count but his obligation is to
get out by the referees count not by a
clock they should use a [ __ ] clock
why don't the use of goddamn clock early
on I used to document Tyson's trainer
Stacy McKinley mm-hmm after he got out
of prison I was and he was I used to
always bring that up with Holyfield in
him like but he was down ten seconds I
don't mean [ __ ] we ain't nobody caring
about that like they they don't use that
as excuse like he was true because he
could have gotten up eight or nine if
they actually have a real clock yeah
it's not like he was out cold and he
woke up at eight
you know I'd say he was he was just
gathering his thoughts and trying to get
his brain straight
[Applause]